[موسيقى]
أنت تعلم أننا كنا مواطنين مثل
أي شخص آخر
ويجب أن نتمتع بنفس الحقوق التي يتمتع بها
[موسيقى]
الآن تذكر أن عمري 11 عامًا قررنا
السير عبر الجسر
ومازلنا لا نفعل ذلك  تعرف أي شيء
كنا نسير للتو، لقد كانت مسيرة أخرى، كما تعلم،
وقع الهجوم هنا وليس على
الجسر،
نقول الجسر لأنه
أقرب
معلم حيث بدأنا رؤية
رجال الشرطة
واعتقدنا أن شيئًا ما لم يكن صحيحًا
لأنه
حتى من هنا أنت  استطعت أن أرى أنه كان هناك
عدد كبير من رجال الشرطة، وليس فقط العمدة
والنواب
وما إلى ذلك ولكن قوات الدولة وكل
شيء كان هنا ثم رأينا
خيولًا وهو أمر غير عادي
ما اعتقدت أنه طلقات نارية وصرخات
واعتقدت أنهم كانوا يقتلون الناس
في المقدمة
لأنهم  من الطلقات النارية ولكن
تبين أنها ليست طلقات نارية، لقد كان
الغاز المسيل للدموع
أولاً، صراخ الطلقات الأولى بالقرب من
الغاز المسيل للدموع،
ثم وصل إلينا الغاز المسيل للدموع وكان
الناس يركضون نحونا،
وقد أخطأنا،
لقد فات الأوان  لقد جاءوا من كلا
الجانبين من الأمام والخلف
وكانوا يضربون الناس فقط، وبدا الأمر
وكأنه استمر إلى الأبد،
إذا تمكنت من
تجاوز هؤلاء الرجال سيرًا على الأقدام، فلن تتمكن من
تشغيل أولئك الذين يمتطون الخيول، كان الأمر مروعًا في
ذلك اليوم، كان الأكثر فظاعة  يوم من حياتي
ما حدث مع وفاة السيد فلويد
ورأيناه يموت في الوقت الحقيقي الذي
لامس بوصلة أمريكا غدًا،
أصيب جاكوب بالرصاص في ظهره سبع مرات
على يد ضابط شرطة،
أود أن أشكر الجميع
على مجيئهم لدعم  ابني
مع محاولة القتل الحمقاء
التي ارتكبت عليه
وعندما رأيته وكانت عيناه
مفتوحتين
على الرغم من أنه كان داخلًا وخارجًا عن
الوعي عندما رآني كان أه أه
يحدق
وقلت أنك تألمت كثيرًا يا عزيزي
وقال لا، أردت فقط
التأكد من ذلك،
هناك نظامان للعدالة في
الولايات المتحدة،
هناك عدالة للأشخاص البيض،
ثم هناك
نحن فقط، إنه عام 2020 وما زلنا نتحدث
عن تسجيل الناخبين
وخسارة الأشخاص من التصويت.
2020 أخي وما زلت جالسًا
هنا أخبرك
أو يجب أن أخبر الناس أن ابني
إنسان، إنه
2020 أخي
وعلينا أن نخبر الناس أننا
جزء من الإنسانية
وأن حياة السود مهمة، ويجب أن
تعرف ذلك بالفعل